Ciao Maryners e benvenuti in un nuovissimo
videoooooo
oggi parleremo di
tatuaggi in particolare dei miei tatuaggi
Spesso infatti mi chiedete ma marina cosa significa quel tatuaggio oppure quanti ne hai a che età hai fatto il primo tatuaggio
perché stai rimuovendo quel tatuaggio insomma tantissime domande quindi
quindi ho deciso di fare un video per rispondere a tutti questi vostri quesiti partirei subito dal primo tatuaggio che mi sono fatta
avevo 16 anni
Non si fanno i tatuaggi a 16 anni bisogna essere maggiorenni ragazzi ricordatevelo
erano le vacanze di pasqua e io ero andata da mio padre in spagna a madrid e mi ero fissata
Che io dovevo tatuarmi quindi cosa è successo mi sono svegliata di prima mattina
papà vado a fare shopping in centro in realtà sono finita a caja della montera che è una vietta appunto che c'è in centro
Dove ci sono solo sexy shop e negozi di tatuaggi
quindi io
spaesatissimo era un po presa male però entro dentro questo, il primo negozio visto neanche mi son stata a informare il primo negozio sono entrata e
Questo tatuatore tipo era messicano mi guarda dalla testa ai piedi
Della serie cosa ci fai qui dentro poppante e mi fa quanti anni hai io chiaramente
ho detto sedici non è che
Ho pensato di dire una bugia e di far finta di averne 18 no perché a me piace dire
La verità quindi sedici anni ok quella è la porta puoi andartene, cosa??
Insisto insisto insisto e alla fine
Lo convinco, lui mi dice chiaramente, se tu domani ti presenti qui dentro, con I genitori o con chiunque
Sappi che io te non ci siamo mai visti quindi questa è una roba illegale la sto facendo ma
la chiudiamo qua, tutto questo bordello
per tatuarmi, voi direte bah si sarà fatta un tatuaggio
Preparatevi
Questo è il tatuaggio cioè rendiamoci conto
era giusto proprio per farsi un tatuaggio perché comunque
Si vede poco coi capelli soprattutto davanti proprio scompare se non, si fosse capito è una m in corsivo
la m di marina chiaramente quindi molto originale mamma mia complimenti
il secondo tatuaggio
in ordine cronologico è questo qua che sto
Rimuovendo perché prima di tutto non mi piace per il motivo principale che non mi piace non lo voglio più vedere
e secondo è che l'ho fatto con uno dei miei primi ragazzi
Che lo ha tra l'altro uguale nello stesso posto
quindi c'erano
motivi a
sufficienza per rimuovere una volta per tutte questo tatuaggio che tra l'altro hp iniziato a odiare col passare degli anni perché in realtà prima
Non ci
facevo così tanto caso però alla fine mi sono accorta che era l'unico tatuaggio che si vedeva così tanto che era così visibile e
Quindi ho iniziato tipo per un periodo a coprirmelo col cerone
Che però poi o si scioglieva col caldo tutto insomma un casino alla fine ho detto bon basta
tagliamo la testa al toro leviamo questo tatuaggio e chi s'è visto s'è visto, questo è quello che rimane di questo tatuaggio, era praticamente un fiore
Fucsia con le foglie verdi e questi  ghirigori neri sta andando via molto bene ne approfitto per rispondere un attimino alle
Domande più frequenti che mi fate sulla rimozione di questo tatuaggio di tatuaggi in generale allora fa male? sì
tanto infatti prima del trattamento
Solitamente metto sempre la crema anestetizzante la seconda domanda che mi fate spesso è
costa rimuovere un tatuaggio?
assolutamente sì costa molto di più rimuovere un tatuaggio rispetto a quanto costa fare un tatuaggio
E il prezzo della seduta varia a seconda della dimensione del tatuaggio dei colori usati dell'inchiostro eccetera eccetera e
considerate che
Non fatte solo una seduta quando rimuovete un tatuaggio ma di solito la rimozione di un tatuaggio necessita
Di più sedute che vengono valutate insieme insomma alla tipologia di tatuaggio e eccetera eccetera quindi vanno via tanti soldi
La cosa un po fastidiosa di quando
Si fa il laser insomma un tatuaggio per rimuoverlo è il mantenimento cioè
Se vai, al mare
Il sole non lo puoi prendere chiaramente ti devi mettere la 50 almeno nella zona
del tatuaggio però
capite che se mi metto la 50 solo qui poi mi rimane la macchia quindi faccio prima a mettermi tutta la 50 sul décolletè
in viso insomma diciamo che il sole lo potete salutare proseguiamo con il terzo tatuaggio che
ho rifatto nello stesso negozio
di tatuaggi
dove avevo fatto questa m qua a madrid sempre
sempre un tatuaggio molto importante molto grosso una chiave di violino
questa fantastica chiave di violino che ormai è sbiadita perché l'ho fatto tanti anni fa come avrete notato c'è un puntino vicino
in realtà è un puntone doveva essere molto più piccolo, mi piaceva l'idea
del musica, punto, cioè della serie per me la musica è tutto era questo il concetto in realtà mi
Ha fatto un punto enorme che sembrava quasi un neo che sto rimuovendo con il laser, il quarto tatuaggio che mi sono fatta
è una
è una Scritta avevo più o meno 21 22 anni
Qualche anno dopo rispetto agli altri. È il titolo di uno dei miei film preferiti
Che ho portato anche che ho inserito anche all'interno della mia tesi di laurea in cinema
italiano ed è la dolce vita quindi è semplicemente
La scritta la dolce vita mi ricordo che quando ho fatto il primo incontro con il mio relatore di tesi
parlando appunto della mia passione per il cinema italiano per fellini eccetera eccetera
Gli dissi no perché io mi sono tatuata
La dolce vita lui mi guardò un po stranito e mi ha chiesto
Ma quale scena? e non ci capivamo lui pensava che mi fossi dipinta cioè mi fossi
tatuata una scena della dolce vita in realtà era solo il titolo però vabbè bastava il pensiero
questo è il famoso tatuaggio della dolce vita e
Devo dire che è stato il tatuaggio piu doloroso di tutti ragazzi non potete capire
Il dolore e, anche perché come vedete qua è tutta ciccia e quindi fa un male cane
E pensateci bene se volete fare un tatuaggio in questo punto
L'ho fatto ribattere inoltre due volte perché la prima volta non mi piaceva che c'erano delle imperfezioni quindi l'ho fatto ribattere. Dopo questa scritta
Ho deciso di fare un'altra scritta a distanza credo di 1 o 2 anni e anche questa molto dolorosa come punto è qua
nel costato, sulle costole
C'è una cosa che mi fa troppo ridere
Tantissimi di voi quando magari pubblico foto o video o musically in cui si vede pensano che sia una ferita
No ragazze è semplicemente un tatuaggio rosso allora lo so che è difficile da decifrare c'è scritto this girl is on fire
allora praticamente this girl is on fire fa parte
Del testo di girl on fire di alicia keys una bellissima canzone che sicuramente tantissimi di voi conosceranno perché
ho deciso di tatuarmi questa frase?
Tutto risale alla prima volta in cui ho sentito questa bellissima canzone e in particolare quando è partito il ritornello
È proprio il momento top della canzone
This girl is on fireeee
Io li, ho sentito proprio dentro una roba esplodere e
E mi ricordo che ho detto no vabbè ma questa me la sentivo troppo questa canzone questa
È la mia canzone questo girl on fire sono io me la devo tatuare questa frase e niente allora il giorno dopo vi giuro sono andata
dal tatuatore e me la sono tatuata avevo anche deciso già il colore , rosso, forse è uno dei pochi tatuaggi
che non mi hanno ancora stufato perché mi piace il punto mi piace Il colore poi questa cosa che a tanti di voi sembra una ferita
È anche molto concettuale perchè effettivamente è come se fosse la cicatrice
Di quel momento della mia vita
Che però grazie a quel momento poi sono esplose insomma non, so se mi sono spiegata
L'ultimo tatuaggio che ho fatto invece è questo cuoricino qui che mi piace un sacco
perché sembra appunto
Disegnato insomma col pennarello colorato col pennarello non sembra un tatuaggio allora questo cuoricino l'ho fatto
Quattro anni fa credo e me lo ha fatto un tatuatore napoletano che ho conosciuto a una convention in puglia pensate un pò, di tatuatori
quando è venuto su a milano
Alla convention qua a milano, l'ho sentito e gli ho detto guarda Paco mi devi assolutamente tatuare questo cuoricino e
In realtà il significato è abbastanza semplice nel senso l'amore per la musica come vedete qua ciò la chiave di violino
E quà il cuoricino e infatti una roba che volevo fare era scrivermi
all i need is qua in mezzo però alla fine non l'ho fatto e forse è stato anche meglio così perché
Diciamo che il polso si vede sempre molto quindi era meglio una roba un pò più soft
concluderei questo video
Consigliando a tutti coloro che mi seguono che hanno in progetto di
tatuarsi insomma stanno pensando a un eventuale tatuaggio di pensarci bene dovete essere sicuri di quello che vi tatuate
Possibilmente io almeno maryna vi consiglia di tatuarvi in posti non
Super visibili perché secondo me a lungo andare poi ci si stanca
e
terzo punto insomma
Non fate tatuaggi con i fidanzati. come al solito se vi è piaciuto
Il video ricordatevi di iscrivervi al canale e di
Cliccare sulla campanella che trovate vicino al tasto di iscrizione per rimanere sempre aggiornati su tutti I miei video ricordatevi anche di seguirmi
Su tutti gli altri social cioè facebook instagram e musically
Io vi mando un bacione e mi raccomando
rifletteteci su prima di fare un tatuaggio